fuga a tutti e mobili nazionali sono che
i ragazzi allora oggi volevo fare una
mappa un po particolare non volevo
giocare a normalmente ma ci sono anche
le custom maps seguito l'avete vista
probabilmente l'utenza crea delle mappe
i mode perché non delle mappe apposta
per divertirsi e questa che voglio
provare oggi si chiama per me ed allora
ho la cos'è af ae aiuto prefettura ma
devo portare anche la palla non so vista
di uccello vediamo a ti fa vedere
all'altro come oche perfetto allora non
non credo richieda delle skill e di volo
particolare in meno allora labirinto e
questo non vedo neanche dove la palla in
tutto sto casino velino su dove la
partenza due partenze o aiuto quale di
queste due quella giusta non capisco
allora dato hanno capito se devo devo
portarono la palla perché secondo me la
palla fosse già sbagliato non sono
neanche entrato benissimo
l'obiettivo è portarla senza fondamento
che le fondamente far toccare il terreno
ok allora destra e poi sinistra quindi
sì avevo ragione a meglio forse
scavalcare
ovviamente no già non mi ricordo più
niente prova bene andiamo paralre aver
sbagliato perfetto non ho idea
posso andare anche senza palla ragazzi
che se come la palla è veramente un
ostacolo mica da ridere perché per farla
centrare una volta vorranno riesco a
corpo del demonio senza ma la ragazzina
abbastanza l'importante è che tanto lo
faccio finire il video i se ne frega
l'hanno fatto enorme storia abbia come
possono non solo pensare che avete kiss
preciso dice che c'è una dolce si vede
niente ma come faccio a vico che si può
vincere questa mappa come l'hanno potuta
fare anche online potrai vincere azione
però fatto un pochino districato allora
mi viene da pensare che se io riesco ad
andare avanti un tot significa che sto
andando giusto cioè non ci sono strade
sbagliate molto moon 10 in genere se
sbagli sbagli subito tipo adesso limbo
compone di subito sbagliato video rica
mente almeno questo
almeno questo dovrebbe essere
praticamente mi dovrei portare la palla
poi c'è point per capire dove sono stato
e dove no ho qua per adesso ragazzi come
sta andando molto bene e non è male non
è male andiamo di nuovo a sinistra
perfetto
io uomo che sa giocare bellissimo
devo trovare dei check point inventando
fisiche con le luci secondo me perché
sono non capisco una sega verticale sono
tutti verticale morì che c'è questa
golino con una luce rossa ok quindi
angolino con ruggiero luce rossa ci sono
già stato perfetto facciamo angolino per
una ics rosso che io faccio di qua non
vale
di questi sono i check point nel
cervello non saprei come crearne altri
ok ok ok non male non male il buon
favino male questa sono tutte strade
chiuse tranne credo questa orco del
demonio ma non è un casino raga
ecco aiuto ragazzine del no nota bene se
premi e r1 e la palla si ripresenta atti
resetti anche tu per ora va tutto bene
ragazzi potrà andare peggio della destra
123 qua a sinistra perfetto veniamo
ancora all and very nice
poi non mi va di mezzo non ho capito
come ho fatto ad arrivare dove è
arrivato pibe pensa se noi se avessi
dovuto portarmi la palla pensa se
fossimo dovuti visit card
la barbagianna sarebbe stato veramente
impossibile per noi ragazzi sto
soffrendo come un cane ma sto
proseguendo che abbiamo non so come mi
sembra di poter dire non so che non me
lo dice il mio sesto senso d'avventura
che vi abbiano sto proseguendo non so
come sia possibile non ci sto capire chi
sta venendo da vomitare non fu
scherzando spero che a voi non facesse
servendo
lobby vedo la lobby e l'onta vedo la
lobby in alto quindi teoricamente siamo
non ha più normale non male perché la
lobby se in quel punto lontano
teoricamente la se mancano e fino a cio
sperando di andare giusti madonna che
casino
ok ok lobby stallato quindi io
teoricamente che comunque vicino alla
lobby se ci pensate il traguardo quindi
non è sbagliata stare vicino alla lobby
però il traguardo secondo me per
raggiungere travolto ci metterò ancora
non sa questo presentimento eccoci qua
perfetto dalla destra destra ci siamo ci
siamo e la parte giusta
ve lo dico ma che cazzo dicendo lo
capisco niente
a cantare una canzone per ricordarci da
una sigla dei pokémon york c'è ma che
non p completarmi video giovanni grazie
voglio andare dove riva e non fermarmi
qua
questo viaggio mi porterà ed a tutti i
pokémon girovagando come è uno stronzo
la mia sfera lancero etto tipo che mi
avvicino non mi sento e tutti i pokemon
così il saluterò viva i fatti e non ci
voglio credere
non ci posso credere hayden e ce l'ho
fatta davvero regalo ci credo non
ragazzi era enorme come il mio camp nou
ragazzi vi giuro famiglie cervello che
stava andando appunto meno male meno
male io vi do ragazzino ci credo
cosa ci ha messo un quarto per noi ci ho
messo meno di un quarto d'ora 12 minuti
avete visto
vi giuro che ci ha messo pochissimo
rispetto a quanto pensato che veramente
pensavo diventa citati di film come noto
very nice ragazze really nice
per i fucking blu è andata veramente di
culo perché per una nuvola genere capace
che ci stai ore ma ore ore vere meno
male che il senso dell'orientamento del
pari mio cervello è fatto di labirinti
nelle istruzioni ce l'ha scritto sei
giochi da solo ti consiglio di portare
alla mappa con te visto che il labirinto
da solo e molto molto molto difficile
io mi sarei dovuto portare la mappa e
avrete dovuto fare sta roba cercando di
seguire la mappa io l'ho fatto senza
spero che il video vi sia piaciuto spero
che avete apprezzato le mie doti le mie
skill labirintiche niente ci vediamo non
prossimo video ragazzi mete lasciare mi
piace le schede al canale
fateci sapere se vi piacciono le mappe
workshop questa era la prima un
tentativo di marcia pro ce ne sono tante
e varie quindi posso provare a fare
tante cose per chi scrive al calcio che
mi piace e noi ci vediamo come sempre al
prossimo vinto dai ragazzi
[Musica]